حج يديك العافيه الله يعافيك شو شو اللي
صار كيف القصه والله انطلقنا من منطقه
جباليه وكانت الاخت يعني في بتطلق زي ما
بقولوا وكانت بتصيح وبتعلي صوتها على قد
جتها وصلنا عند محطه الندر بالضبط سمعنا
صوت
المولود يعني نزل الجنين من بطن امه داخل
السياره احنا بنمشي بال السياره قاعدين
وصلنا محطه الندر قبل قبل منطقه جبال
المعسكر في اول جبال المعسكر طبعا سمعنا
صوت المولود اي وتوجهنا للعياده العصريه
مباشره وصفينا السياره قدام العياده
العصريه وتم تغطيه السياره بالبطاطين وطلع
دكتور من من المستشفى يعني نتحدث عن عمليه
ولاده داخل السياره البنت ظهر تمت ولادتها
داخل السياره والدكتور كان ج السياره وطلع
البنت من جووا السياره
وغلف بملايه و دخلناه على المستشفى بعدين
الام نزلت تلقت العلاج في العياده العصريه
وبعدين توجهنا لمستشفى العوده
ستال
ه